from action throwbacks to kid-friendly
fare hard-hitting dramas to
game-changing horror this year has
already delivered a bumper crop of
excellent flicks for film lovers we're
just a few pages into the calendar but
let's take a quick look back at the best
movies of 2017 so far the Lego Batman
movie trying to follow up the lego movie
was a tough proposition and spinning off
Will Arnett's Batman into his own movie
could easily have backfired the
filmmakers could have faulted under the
pressure of making the Batman likable or
interesting enough to carry his own film
or buckled under the weight of all those
DC Comics in jokes and gags crazy quilt
eraser polkadot man my tarantula in car
Orca he'll Vermont or Carrie Doniak
master gentleman go happily the Lego
Batman movie turns out to be one of the
best family-friendly movies in ages
while tucking in enough smart comic
stuff to keep Batman geeks coming back
for repeat viewings fun wacky and a
rollicking adventure in the wild world
of Lego the movies being showered with
praise from critics who are calling it
one of the best animated offerings of
the year and one of the best Batman
movies ever John wick chapter 2 more
than 15 years after the matrix saga
began Keanu Reeves has reinvented
himself as an action hero for a whole
new generation this sequel to his
surprise action hits on weck is a
bone-crushing r-rated thrill ride that
finds reeves names like hitman pulled
out of retirement to take on a shady
international conspiracy so I guess you
have a choice you want a war
or do you want to just give me a gun
sure it's mostly just a setup for Reeves
to kick and shoot a bunch of bad guy
busts critics however say the film feels
like a throwback to the simpler days of
action films focusing on practical
effects instead of distracting CGI it's
also one of the most stylish films of
the year regardless of genre hidden
figures this historical drama
technically opened late in 2016 but it
didn't go wide until this year it tells
the inspiring true story of the black
women who worked at NASA during the
early days of the u.s. space program and
the critical role she played in helping
America with the space race stars taraji
P Henson Octavia Spencer and Jenna
Monet did a fantastic job of bringing
this era to life while lending genuine
emotional heft to the film's portrayal
of their struggles and triumphs not only
is it a fascinating real-life story it's
uplifting and all-around entertaining
Patriots Day director Peter Bergstrom
attic retelling of the real-life 2013
Boston Marathon bombing stars Mark
Wahlberg making this his third
fact-based thriller with Berg Wahlberg
plays a police sergeant thrust into the
middle of the chaos and the ensuing
investigation of the bombing critics
have praised Patriots day which also
opened a limited release late in 2016
for managing to tell a compelling story
without exploiting the real-life tragedy
while some reviews question whether it's
too soon to bring this particular story
to the Cineplex but there's no denying
it brings Berg and Wahlberg in their
wheelhouse and the lets wahlberg be bust
in as all get-out yes outlet in Boston
work for us and telling you split pretty
much no one thought us coming but M
night Shyamalan surprised hit split
is among the best films of the year that
sorta thriller follows a group of young
women abducted by a man played by James
McAvoy with multiple personalities and
those personalities struggle for
dominance threatened to upend his plans
or make things even worse those captives
critics have hailed it as an unexpected
return to form for the writer director
and the big part of the film both came
from sham alarms traditional big twist
in the final act and isn't just the
shocking fact that the twist is actually
good this time that makes splits so much
fun either McAvoy ties it all together
with a tour de force performance the
founder this true story follows ray kroc
played by Michael Keaton and the twisty
real-life saga of how the McDonald's
fast food chain was born for those who
have never stopped to consider the Big
Macs origin story it's a surprisingly
timely tale that delves into the dark
side of the American Dream I just cannot
stop thinking about this tremendous
restaurant critics have praised Keaton
for his multifaceted performance and
while some of notice that the movie
could have dug a little deeper it all
goes down about as easy as a Mickey D's
shake did I have crash D partially
gelatinous non-dairy gun-based beverages
mmm they call them shakes two shakes no
no what you can get out point to our
February
horror-movie on your average release
calendar and you're probably singling
out a pretty lame film but there's
always an exception this year get out is
that amazing exception helmed by
first-time feature director Jordan Peele
of key and Peele Fame everybody here
gets to design my own gremlin this
horror comedy hybrid follows the
increasingly frightening misadventures
of a younger man of venturing into the
suburbs to meet his girlfriend's parents
they have no idea he's black until he
arrives which feeds into the film's
creeping tension but of course that's
only the start thrilling as it is
thought-provoking this is one 20-17
movie no film buff will want to miss
Logan comics fans have loved Wolverine
for decades partly because the character
has a dark violent streak a mile wide
and although Hugh Jackman has played the
x-men just about perfectly
none of those outings have truly
captured the grueling angst and
berserker rage that helped make his saga
so poignant
that's all changes with Logan at least
adaptation of the old man Logan comic
book story that finds our hero in a grim
wasteland called upon to defend a
mysterious girl targeted by a pack of
bloodthirsty villains a brooding western
roadtrip with claws Logan's being hailed
by critics as a fitting farewell for
Jackman and perhaps the best entry in
the x-men franchise to date Kong Skull
Island it's been a long time coming but
Warner Brothers and legendary pictures
knocked it out of the part of the
new-look version of King Kong in Skull
Island
the story follows a team of explorers
and soldiers as they head off to a
mysterious island that turns out to be
the home of giant monsters critics have
been raving about the a-list cast
praising the aesthetics of the 1970s
setting and saying it strikes the
perfect balance of big stakes dumb fun
and a wildly enjoyable action I can't go
crores why
never said that name out loud before it
sounds stupid now that I say just you
call them whatever you want
it also looks to set the stage for an
eventual crossover with Godzilla that
will set up the studios monster verse
Skull Island is only the beginning
with luck we'll finally get that modern
reboot of the greatest monster story
ever told
Godzilla's journey to become a great dad
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Applause]